j'étais un premier ministre heureux
c'est difficile à dire vu les épreuves
que nous avons traversé mais il n'ya pas
d'en faire un matignon il n'y a que le
service de la france bien sûr il ya eu
beaucoup de gravité et elle ne m'a
jamais quitté cette gravité
nous l'avons éprouvé ensemble tous les
deux trente deux mois avec des moments
difficiles éprouvant il y a eu bien sûr
les attentats il y à cette menace mais
vous étiez ministre de l'intérieur est
en première ligne pour faire face à
cette menace terroriste
trente deux mois qu'ils ont pu être
aussi des moments de joie de plaisir
je ne pense pas uniquement à la demi
finale de l'euro de foot et je sais
votre amour pour le ballon rond vous
avez appris à connaître
il y a quelques mois les moments de
bonheur ou si je pense au succès de la
coop 21 parce que la france dans ces
moments-là parle au monde
et puis bien sûr une politique au
service de redressement de la
compétitivité la baisse des impôts pour
les couches moyennes
les classes populaires et ce bilan ce
travail qui a été l'hôte vous avez
contribué aussi dans vos différentes
fonctions depuis 2012 vous y avait
contribué
ce travail ces réformes ce bilan nous
devons l'assumer et bien évidemment je
l'assumé